hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 141 I am Dr
Brett Weinstein this is Dr Heather Hein
and you may notice that we are back in
the Portland Studio we did in fact move
uh I came back uh earlier to start uh
well not start we've been packing but uh
I came back and was packing Heather
joined me a couple days later Zach is
now sitting in the producer's chair for
what will be the last broadcast from
here
here we are in our Portland Studio our
final our final live stream from
Portland uh we'll be breaking down the
studio as soon as we finish here and uh
coming to you next week and in the
future from our new home about which we
will talk about today so today is going
to be dedicated to talking about
Portland which has been our home for
four years in which we love but which is
doing a very poor job of staying awesome
even though it still has a lot of
awesome bits so that's our plan for
today we are not going to do a q a today
but we will next week
we encourage you to go to our store in
talking about what we're talking about
today we will point you to some new
merch there but just at the moment say
you can find our store at uh
darkhorsestore.org
that's where it is uh come find me at
Natural Selections my sub stack where
this week I posted a piece that I called
misunderstanding science speaking to the
the the question of how it is that so
many people who are highly educated and
appear to be highly intelligent seem to
have no understanding of what science is
and say things like follow the science
and are quite certain that those of us
who don't agree with the rapidly formed
consensus on some of the modern things
that ALS must be conspiracy theorists as
opposed to approaching the world
scientifically so that's that's this
week in on Natural Selections we are
supported by our audience that is you we
are very grateful to you we are
streaming right now on YouTube and
honestly the chat's live on Odyssey we
will of course show up on all of the all
of the usual places shortly in short
order Spotify and
um and apple podcasts and and every
place and uh and for YouTube and odyssey
we of course have clips that go out at
Dark Horse podcast Clips uh which uh
which are quite attractive to people and
we encourage you to share to like to
subscribe to the channels uh to to talk
it up uh because that is word of mouth
is is how things spread how how dark
horse uh continues to have its audience
uh especially given that some among the
big Tech have demonetized us we are uh
largely
um audience supported right which is in
fact the meaning of that uh sword back
there which will have to be moved the
Sword of Damocles which hangs still
above the Dark Horse uh we put that
there when we were demonetized by
YouTube and because of course they have
uh just simply let that stand even
though they are now putting ads on our
podcasts
um in any case that sword will have to
be moved with the podcast
um yeah it's interesting actually I mean
this is we're still just an intro
territory here but a number of people
have commented that uh in the last week
or so there have been even more ads uh
in the middle of and during uh YouTube
versions of our podcasts and I went and
looked and it's true and we're not
seeing any of that money so uh YouTube
is advertising on our show uh while
keeping us fully demonetized and part of
the reason they told us they demonetized
us was that our content was incompatible
with their sponsors clearly that is not
true they would simply prefer that we
not see any profit from their profit
well more to the point as was clear from
the beginning of their demonetization
they are punishing us and they are
punishing us for saying things that they
don't want said but uh they are
perfectly happy to uh to make revenue
from the podcast because of course
there's nothing you know what we're
saying makes sense and so people listen
and it's a perfectly viable place for
ads
um
there I do want to make one technical
announcement we have had the failure of
the computer that runs the podcast this
morning
um and that means that we are running
from a different computer and have no
backup should the podcast go off the air
during uh we will not be able to reboot
the stream in all likelihood and so just
know that that is what has happened we
don't expect it at this point but it
could it could occur
so we appreciate you subscribing liking
sharing sharing the material and if you
are in a position to support us in
additional ways we have patreons where
we do a private monthly q a online we
have we have bread house conversations
on his and on both of them you can
access our wonderful Discord server and
of course we have sponsors we carefully
pick and choose the sponsors who are
brought To Us by our wonderful ad broker
and what that means for you is that if
you hear us reading an ad and you can
always know if you're watching that this
is a this is a paid promotion when
you've got that green perimeter around
the screen if you hear us reading
something that means that we have
actually vetted directly or in a couple
of cases including one of today's
sponsors because we have no ability to
vet it directly had somewhere we are
close to but it directly and we actually
stand by this product so if you hear us
reading a script for a a a product or a
service that you've been wondering about
you can be certain that we are actually
vouching for it whether that means that
it will be right for you that's for you
to decide so without further Ado here
are three
sponsors uh for this week seed MD
hearing aid and all form our first
sponsor this week is seed seed is a
company focused on bacteria and the
microbiome and they have a terrific
probiotic called ds01 daily synbiotic
that's with an n
there are a lot of things that you can
do to enhance your health our sign off
here at Dark Horse includes three of
them you go to the ones you love eat
good food and get outside but a lot is
hidden in those words what for instance
constitutes good food good food is real
food whole food food that has been alive
recently and was grown with care and
conditions as ancient as possible given
the constraints of the 21st century but
even when many people who eat such a
diet but even many people who eat such a
diet are missing something
we contain multitudes every individual
human contains so many other organisms
some of which might harm us but many of
which exist with us in harmony we need
them this is why probiotics can be an
important tool in a healthy lifestyle
even if you eat nutrient-dense food and
avoid processed foods and Seed oils and
sugar
that said probiotics are kind of the new
current thing aren't they everyone's
taking them or thinking of taking them
and it can seem like maybe it's just a
fad good news though seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic is the real deal not all
probiotics are created equally it turns
out seeds dso1 daily symbiotics a broad
spectrum two in one probiotic and
Prebiotic it contains 24 distinct
probiotic strains and here's where it
gets very interesting
I think in a two-in-one capsule that
protects the probiotics until they hit
the colon which where they are most
effective so if you've taken a probiotic
for and you've found that it doesn't do
anything for you it's likely because uh
that pill was getting digested uh in
your in your foregut and didn't survive
uh to get to the place where it needs to
be seed is designed differently and
that's why it works and I can attest
it's quite a quite a remarkable product
seeds daily symbiotic supports gut skin
and heart health and micronutrient
synthesis many who have used seed report
improvements to the digestive function
in 24 to 48 hours start a new healthy
habit today visit seed.com Darkhorse and
use code Darkhorse to redeem 20 off your
first month of seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic that's seed.com
s-e-e-d.com slash Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse
okay our second sponsor this week is MD
hearing aid this is not a product that
we ourselves need so we asked a good
friend who does and you will hear her
testimonial mid-add here MD hearing aid
was founded by an ENT surgeon who made
it his mission to develop a quality
hearing aid that anyone could afford
recognizing that about 95 of the people
who need a hearing aid only require a
few settings he removed some of the less
often needed components he also cut out
the middleman and now empty hearing aid
makes a rechargeable hearing aid that is
FDA registered and costs a small
fraction of what typical hearing aids
cost these hearing aids aim to fit so
well that no one will know you're
wearing them the rechargeable batteries
last up to 30 hours their vault plus
model is water resistant and up to three
feet of water and you don't need a
prescription you buy it directly from
the source where audiologists and
licensed hearing Specialists are
available seven days a week everyone can
empathize with what it feels like to be
left out of a conversation others are
enjoying here's a testimonial from that
friend of ours who has substantial
hearing loss and who relies on hearing
aids we asked her if she would try the
product and this is what she said with
my particular type of hearing loss a
deep male voice in a noisy room is the
hardest situation for me to hear and
understand speech I wore the MD hearing
aid to have a conversation with a deep
voice man in a room with a lot of white
noise the MD hearing aid passed the test
as my conversation partner's voice was
clear and understandable at a price
point of under a thousand dollars I was
amazed at how effective they are
MD hearing aid has brought affordable
hearing to over six hundred thousand
satisfied customers plus they offer a
45-day risk-free trial with 100 money
back guarantee get Clinic level care for
80 less with MD hearing aid go to
mdhearingaid.com and use promo code
Darkhorse to get their new buy one get
one deal a pair of hearing aids cost
just
149.99 Dark Horse listeners receive a
free extra charging case a hundred
dollar value so head to mdhearingaid.com
that's
mdhearing h-e-a-r-i-n-g Aid aid.com
and use promo code Darkhorse to get
their new buy one get one deal a pair of
hearing aids for only 149.99
all right
our final sponsor this week is all form
a company that makes terrific custom
sofas we like them so much we have two
of them in fact during last week's live
stream we were sitting on one of them
some people commented on how nice it
looked well as nice as it looked it
feels even better what makes this sofa
so terrific for a fraction the cost of
traditional sofas you can customize size
layout Fabric and color they do
armchairs and love seats all the way up
to an eight seat sectional this is the
easiest way to customize a sofa and the
quality is fantastic furthermore they
are beautiful and comfortable roomy and
adaptable all four sofas are delivered
directly to your home free and fast and
assemble assembly is easy we started
with one beautiful sectional all-form
sofa in whiskey leather it's soft and
supple and warm unlike a lot of leather
we all pile on it to watch movies some
evenings it looks gorgeous and it is
incredibly inviting and comfortable a
rare combination
we liked it so much we got a second one
also some listeners asked if all form
holds up to pets yes it does the leather
that all form uses is 20 thicker than
typical Furniture leather and shows
nowhere despite the fact that both cats
and the dog lie on the couch many
evenings and if you prefer fabric all
form Fabrics are three and a half times
more durable than industry standard for
heavy duty Fabrics so their Fabrics are
going to hold up really well with peps
also
finally they offer a forever warranty
literally forever to find your perfect
sofa check out allform.com
Darkhorse all form is offering twenty
percent off all orders to our listeners
at allform.com
Darkhorse step up your sofa game today
all right that is our ads for the week
so
this is our last
it's our last podcast in our in our
Portland Studio
this is the waning days of us being
residents of Portland
and it is Bittersweet to be sure we are
very very sorry to be going where should
we where should we start well I wanted
to I'm going to focus on Portland today
I have a lot of photos that will cue us
to um to talk about various things that
I know you and I both want to cover but
I wanted to start with
um
a story which I hope will not strike
people as odd
when I went to I spent an hour on Tucker
Carlson's program and I got a chance to
speak this is a year ago over a year ago
yeah and he asked me as we were sitting
down preparing he said where are you
living and I said Portland and I
expected the usual reaction that one
gets from conservatives I expected a
snide comment or something like geez
that must be rough something like that
and that's not what happened I said I
that Heather and I live in Portland and
he got wistful he said
I love Portland and I thought you know
this is really the problem is that
Portland has become a caricature yeah
and it shouldn't be Portland is a
tragedy because it is a marvelous City
failing to live up to its amazing
potential
and I I was heartened to hear that he
had a relationship with he's kind of an
outdoorsy guy a do-it-yourself sort of
person and the fact that you know he'd
been here and you know this is a great
American city and he registered it as
such
um gave me a certain kind of hope
that said you know you and I I feel I
still love Portland it's not even that I
loved it when we moved here or loved the
idea of moving here I still love it yep
but it does not feel tenable it feels
less tenable with every passing month
yeah it does and you know I we aren't
the sort of people who see signs coming
from the Universe
um but I have to say the fire apocalypse
that's happening in Oregon right now and
is causing the skies to be you know deep
orange gray when the weather app assures
us that it's sunny out and the Sun is a
glowing orb of angry red orange uh I you
know hopefully this doesn't become what
happened two years ago just about now uh
where you know portlanders and lots of
people in surrounding areas were
basically
um you know if you were lucky enough
that it didn't come so close that you
had to evacuate and a lot of people did
uh locked in your home hoping that you
had good air filtration because the air
quality was the worst in the world for
uh gosh I think it was over a week it
was it was bad and you know the air is
thick now you can sort of taste it it's
it's
it's Smoky out there uh and it feels
like
yep
there is a lot to recommend the culture
actually and the nature of this place
and both of them are failing in some
rather extraordinary ways yeah they are
they are failing and you know it's a
it's a step remote from what we want to
talk about but you know even the fact of
unmanageable fires in the west is the
result of naive fire policy in large
measure and so there's a way in which
naive policy is really the problem as
we've talked about before
Portland actually not only could it
function brilliantly and I should tell
you the slogan of the city is the city
that works
it's increasingly ironic because it
really doesn't work but um but the point
is not only could Portland work
but Portland is in a position to
um
benefit from the failure of all of the
other West Coast cities yeah right all
it has to do is not make those mistakes
and if it did that it would collect so
much revenue that it could actually work
really well and in fact benefit all of
the people that we pretend in Portland
are this the center of this uh policy
Fiasco the reason that we are doing
these things there will be a lot of
people listening you know we know we
have a lot of audience in Portland
because we're approached by you and we
appreciate that and we are sorry to uh
to about not to be sharing our city with
you anymore uh but for people who've
never lived on the west coast and uh you
know if if you're watching Dark Horse
you are either liberal and disenchanted
and disenfranchised or you're
conservative and so many people have
never lived in the west coast wonder why
anyone would at this point right and at
some level you have to you have to have
experienced the West Coast the natural
beauty and the culture and and the DIY
ethos and you know just a lot here that
is not found any place else we've been
you know there's a lot of places in the
world we haven't been and I um actually
haven't really spent any time in the
American South but I've spent time in
all in all the other quadrants of this
country plus a lot of other countries
and the west coast of the United States
is a particular kind of awesome and as
we are going to come back to we'd like
to keep it awesome we'd like to keep it
weird as you said uh on I don't know a
recent podcast you know let's you know
Keep Austin Weird Keep Portland Weird it
was adopted from the Keep Austin Weird
and that suggests a kind of alternative
you know artsy let's look at things
differently approach well let's Keep
Portland Weird Western educated
industrialized Rich Democratic and the
whole West Coast is looking like it's
sort of throwing up its ants at the
whole Endeavor going nah the West was
fine while it lasted but never mind
anyway right the West well the
the West is uh somehow the core of the
problem rather than a prototype that has
not fully uh reached its potential yeah
no I was I wasn't quite done there let
me just you said a number of things
before that I wanted to respond to and
I've forgotten some of them now but
there's one thing in particular uh that
you said that the motto of Portland is
apparently the city that works and I
don't I feel like it's also the rose
seat like there's a lot of things that
identify cities so I don't know exactly
like I I'm not going to claim to know
that that is true but I've heard that
before that is something that is said
about it's not all the trucks okay
that are running or the ones that are
broken down by the side of the road no
no the ones that are struggling to keep
Portland barely functional yeah uh well
so we were at dinner last night and uh
sitting outside on the patio of an
amazing restaurant we'll talk a little
bit about some of the places that that
we love hear and recommend um but I'm
not gonna do that right now but outside
we're in slab town for those of you who
know poor Island in Northwest
quadrant of the city and there's a
homeless guy outside out in this is like
a patio with sort of some barriers and
he's on the sidewalk right on the other
side of the patio patio and he had a
clipboard that he was appearing to take
notes and sometimes he'd just like
Scribble furiously and so he'd like look
at the cars and take notes I'm like guys
cosplaying as a municipal worker
this guy is acting like as a city
employee but he has nothing he has no
idea what that would actually involve
and I you know I have no idea what you
know what was wrong with him or what you
know was he involved in some kind of
performance art he was having a
conversation with someone that we could
not see and he was uh jotting things
down on his clipboard now I will say we
are not making fun of this gentleman he
did appear to be quite happy he did he's
not an angry homeless no he did and he
wasn't accosting but I would also point
out yeah
what he was doing
is not going to work but it's no worse
than what the city government is doing
which is also not working so ah you see
what I'm saying yes yes so maybe he
heard the motto or saw one of those
tracks went oh the city that works well
I'm in the city I guess I'll get to work
then this way if you told me that he was
running for mayor and you didn't tell me
anything else about him if he was
running against the current mayor
I might have to vote for him I mean he's
at least got a clipboard okay so I'll
bet wheeler can Source himself a
clipboard I bet you but right but I
think he would probably destroy it as a
measure to decolonize the city from the
Western clipboard orientation or I don't
know what it is that he would do reports
are probably a sign of the patriarchy or
something uh yeah yeah it's definitely
it's it's part of the problem they
demonstrate the hegemonic unification of
the I don't I don't know the words
anymore yeah I'm free enough of that
landscape but you know time was I could
put together some uh some sort of word
solid postmodern crap but all I got
right now is hegemony right exactly
exactly which I would pronounce
differently but that is uh Germany uh
hegemony hegemony hegemony oh right I
turned it into the noun form without
correcting where the syllable went yeah
right exactly yeah all right well okay I
I'm going to since you don't know what
photographs I've got some of them are
actually with you when you took some of
them but I don't know what you got right
um Zach would you start with the first
photograph we will describe these for
people who are just listening I don't
think you actually need to see that so
first thing I wanted to say is that I
think I didn't really understand what
Portland was until we moved to the
Pacific Northwest Portland feels like a
coastal city it is not a coastal city
Portland is actually a city defined by
Two Rivers this picture that we have up
is the Willamette River which runs
through the center of Portland it
literally divides West Portland from
East Portland
and it is a beautiful River it is a
river on which you can have a lot of fun
you do a lot of paddle boarding there I
went out on my last paddle board
yesterday morning yep on it there are
these uninhabited islands that you could
pull up on and sit and write ah it's
gorgeous it's lovely gorgeous
um we have kayaked on it we have kayak
to uh to dinner that's uh something that
we've done here it's really it's really
quite lovely and even if you're you have
to put the kayaks on a rack and put me
on a car and everything to put in but
it's a pain in the butt yeah it's worth
it but anyway the point is even if
you're on land the rivers have an
important
um uh impact on life here Portland it's
funny I was struggling with the question
of is it a beautiful city and I think
the other River as you said yeah the
other rivers bounds the north which is
the Columbia the now tame once Mighty
Columbia River which separates Oregon
from Washington right which is on the
border between Oregon and Washington and
it is at the North edge of Portland
proper
um but it has unless you're at that very
edge which is where the airport is and I
guess there's there must be industrial
stuff there but most people don't have a
regular interaction with the Columbia
but most portlanders
um have somewhat I I would think
certainly we do have nearly daily
interactions with the women with yes
exactly and
um so I was struggling with the question
of is it a beautiful city and what I
concluded is Portland is not a beautiful
city because there's nowhere to look at
it from about the only time I ever feel
like I'm looking at Portland is the
bridges which especially at night when
the city is lit up it's very stunning
gorgeous um but it is not a city that
you can look out from anywhere but
living here the air is clean the water
is excellent
um I think it's a beautiful city I think
I think that's a strange
um
standard like most cities don't have a
place where you can see the city and go
like oh look at that well you know it's
funny because we grew up in La I spent a
lot of time at the observatory there is
some Observatory yeah you there is a
place you can look down in L.A that's a
very particular situation yeah I agree
yeah I agree but all right um in any
case it is a city that is quite far
inland but feels like a coastal city I
mean it's Portland right it's got two
rivers that have ports on them so it is
a city that is defined by the uh
Commerce largely logging originally the
nickname of Portland is Stumptown which
doesn't evoke anything as well I think
yeah Stumptown and you mentioned
Slabtown uh where we dined last night's
Slabtown is a reference to these large
wooden slabs that people make things
like tables out of Slabtown doesn't have
any Mills in it anymore but once upon a
time that's what was done there but
anyway it's the ports that Define the
place and caused it to be here
um but they are not uh they are ports
for ocean-going vessels but it is
definitely a town on Rivers
um which has a an impact on it it is not
like San Francisco or La uh or San Diego
or Seattle or even Seattle even though
Seattle's not in the ocean but it's at
the near enough to the entrance to the
Puget Sound The Street of San Juan de
Fuca that it's got it's it's
closer to the source yeah yeah all right
uh next picture Zach
so this is uh Manson's Summit and I just
put this in there uh because this is
this is the nice part of Portland right
this is a tiny little summer in a
neighborhood yeah it's the sunset last
night and this is a place that on here
you could see how much particular matter
there is in the air yeah you can already
see the fire glorious Sunset like that
unless you got a lot of stuff in there
yeah sorry but people go up there any
summer night and often nights during
other parts of the year it's a great
place to watch hummingbirds there's you
know bees have become uncommon in uh in
the Western World probably as a result
of neonicotinamide pesticides but
there's still lots of bees up at the
summit but anyway it's a summit it's
about a thousand feet uh off the
Willamette which is about at sea level
and you know this is a place people
quietly gather and anyway you're looking
at you can't see it right now but you're
looking West obviously because it's
Sunset out over the Coast Range Beyond
which is the Pacific Ocean but that's
what about 100 miles away someone like
that yep maybe it's a little less than
that but this is a favorite spot and you
know there was there was a young couple
in love up there yesterday there were
some uh it was an established couple
sitting on a bench talking about I don't
know what but you know this is just a
nice little spot
um and there was us apparently
eavesdropping yes apparently we were we
were ease dropping uh all right so
anyway that's um that's sort of that's
part of the you know the air is clean
except for smoke sometimes
um the water is good uh and you know
it's a it's a good healthy climb up
there on your bike it's a it's a nice uh
healthy way to live a lot of people
value being outside and
um not taking
orders uh from larger entities about how
to run their lives yep all right Advance
it one
and here this is um
a living mural on the side of a building
that has an excellent Cuban restaurant
in it Palomar Palomar and so what I mean
by living mural is that it's a mural
it's a fanciful rendering of a woman
um but her hair is alive her hair is
plants and this is a gigantic mural in
fact yeah this is what a six-story
building something like that yeah
something like that during the pandemic
when eating outside was uh preferable to
eating inside and understood to be so
the restaurant limited its menu and it
moved the roof which was glorious it had
some trees up there and they uh sweeping
views like oh yeah 360 views you could
couldn't get 360 in one spot but you
could walk around and see entirely
around the building which is it's on the
east side of the river but not too far
so you can look across the river to the
West Side to downtown to the Pearl and
you can see all over on the east side as
well out to Mount Hood yep and that was
always windy and warm and windy up there
in the summer during covid and you could
look down on this mural for from above
which was cool could you yep absolutely
absolutely you could stand right there
behind the lights and and look down
couldn't really see much of it though no
you could it was quite distorted at that
proximity but uh
but anyway
um it's a very cool place and you know
it it again speaks to the good part of
Portland right I you know this is an
it's a provocative image an interesting
one to look at and the idea of doing it
with you know that's got to be a hell of
a lot of work to water those plants on
the side of that building and yet
somebody has thought to do it and
maintained it and it looks great
uh you want to go one more and here
again is a nice this is uh looking out
into Pioneer Square this is a statue a
metal statue of a guy with an umbrella
of course an allusion to the the weather
which although the summers are always
beautiful here it's pretty constantly
rainy for you know uh I don't know nine
months this is an old enough statue that
he's hailing a cab you don't really do
anymore right no he's not hailing an
Uber that's true
um but it's wonderful so that's um sorry
go back there for a second Zach if you
could
um he's up and this raised part of
Pioneer Square where there are always
three or four food trucks and if you're
standing around either waiting to order
your food or waiting for your food to
come out like for a year or so we had an
office right overlooking Pioneer Square
uh and so we would go to fried egg I'm
in love the food truck man that was good
um and when you're waiting around no
matter how many times you see the statue
you catch this guy the corner of your
eye like oh is that oh
[Music]
yeah it's a great statue you mentioned
fried egg I'm in love which is a really
cool food truck we don't have a picture
of it but the fried egg I'm in love not
only makes an incredible series of
sandwiches but every sandwich is a
wicked pun based on music of the 80s
right
um so I mean the title of the restaurant
is obviously an illusion I think to the
Cure but in any case
um
so it's playful right it's exactly what
Portland should be I mean it's
experiment culture in Portland is
amazing like I said we're going to keep
on mentioning restaurants that we've
loved but um
a food truck food truck culture is real
in Portland this is one food truck of
many in the middle of Pioneer Square
that not only are they making amazing
food sourcing local ingredients well
made thinking about the food but they're
also having fun with language yeah
totally and it's it's a it's a marvelous
place but then this is like literally
this statue and you know this statue
that statue is actually looking out
towards the ninth circuit right the
important court building
um for uh the the federal circuit it's
not right there I said it's a block or
so away uh well I actually think it's
right there but no no that's not the go
to the next picture so this is actually
oh yeah there's the courthouse on the
right yeah but I think the ninth go to
the next the ninth circuit may be a
block down but nonetheless it's right
there but here's the here's the dark
side you have this historic Portland so
this is a building that fronts Pioneer
Square right this is this is like you
could see that dude the umbrella holding
taxi hailing statue dude from if you
were looking that statue in the face and
you looked up this is what you'd see
this is a beautiful historic brick
building in the center of downtown and
it is defaced with this graffiti it's a
white brick building that has been
defaced with this unfortunately we are
obscuring some of the most defacing part
of it at the moment the way what our
screen is but on the left
uh you could I mean I it's it seems a
little subtle to me looking at this when
you're there looking at the building
it's so obviously defacing and you know
the only the The only positive sense I
have it's like Well that took some
tenacity like how did they even do that
it's impressive up there for a long time
well it hasn't even been up they have
cleaned it and it's been done and it
goes back and they clean it and it goes
back and this is part of the problem is
that
civilization depends on you being able
to drive up the costs of those who are
violating its rules that's what the laws
are for and we are now making excuses
for law Breakers right well maybe the
graffiti artist is trying to say
something and maybe they don't have an
opportunity to do it and so maybe they
can go to face this important part of
Portland and that's their right and then
we'll clean it up and in fact we will
come back to this pattern but it is the
excuse making
for people who are not living up to our
Collective Agreement with each other
that is actually driving Portland to the
brink of failure no that's right and
that's what's happening in all the
Western cities and frankly I think you
know increasingly all the American
cities but especially all the West Coast
cities
and go on well I just want to point out
that there's a loophole in that which
will be discovered it will be
rediscovered because it always is and
the loophole is a city that does not do
anything to solve the problems that
ultimately cause that wave of malcontent
a city that just simply turns brutal
right that arbitrarily punishes people
who have fallen on hard times will drive
them out to other cities that don't do
that and that City will become marvelous
because it doesn't have those problems
as a result of its brutality so the
point is some city is about to become
brutal
and in so doing reap the benefit of
every other City making excuses well I
mean I I feel like this is maybe the
wrong the wrong point to make with this
particular
image uh I was I was going to say at one
level this is a purely aesthetic
violation right I do think that Portland
is a beautiful city from almost many of
the Vantage points although east of the
river there are many fewer of them
increasingly because you have these just
endless homeless encampments
um some of which are intense some of
which are in the vehicles uh and just
you know destruction all over the place
this is in this is in downtown
um
just west of the Willamette and
as I said it's purely aesthetic and
there's a hell of a lot going on in the
city you know the murder rate is up the
you know the the illegal street racing
wrong way on streets like you know the
you know not responding to 9-1-1 there's
a lot wrong with the city that is
actually putting life in limb uh in
danger and this is merely aesthetic on
the other hand what is it that that
drives people into a place like why why
would you move to a city like Portland
and if they can clean up all the rest of
it which they don't show any signs of
doing then the claim can be well at
least you're less likely to die here
than you were in 2021 uh right but but
what you want is a is a is a city that
fills you with Intrigue with
um with the impetus to explore to be
surprised around a corner with images of
public art and there is a fair amount of
public art but much of it is defaced the
you know the elk statue got ripped down
because Felker racist you know it's it's
completely insane well you mentioned two
things that are really uh opposites that
lead to the same result right we have a
city government that makes excuses for
criminals right and we saw this
throughout the uh the riots yep right we
saw people who people were not arrested
and on those rare occasions when they
were arrested they were immediately
turned back to the city they were they
had people supplying uh legal funding
they had a district attorney who refused
to prosecute a prosecute and so anyway
there's that and the city allowed the
police to be demonized as you you'll see
a little later the idea that all cops
are bastards and that frankly in
Portland you can spray paint on a wall
kill all cops and this is taken to be an
aesthetic flourish rather than a threat
um all of this results in a city that is
increasingly Lawless and you're right
this is an aesthetic violation but the
point is it's about the fact that we
don't punish people instead what we do
is we clean up after them and so yeah go
to the go to the next you know you
you shouldn't be cleaning up after your
five-year-old when in order to make a
point he tips over his apple juice right
you know that's one thing if there's an
accident but at the point that your
five-year-old looks you in the eye and
says what are you gonna do you teach
that five-year-old that he is going to
be responsible for his own actions
somehow we've got a city of people who
apparently were never parents or with
such terrible parents they never
understood that actually teaching people
to be responsible for their own actions
is one of the first roles of a good
parent a good Municipal leadership a
good anything right you you can't you
can't do this this way so we're gonna
need to have this it's going to be
smaller in order to see it scoot that to
the right or have us this is uh graffiti
on a downtown building a boarded up
building and there are a lot of boarded
up buildings in downtown and the
graffiti here which is actually visually
kind of stunning The Art here is
actually impressive it's confident it's
3D not above above is the usual tagging
such but the the word on the bottom
which says decolonize is actually really
interestingly done it's beautifully done
and it's done I actually on boarded up
windows so it's their Dante facing you
know real property I mean right no they
would but yeah
um but it also the incoherence of
decolonize as a claim uh I want to
revive a story we may have talked about
it before but I remember there was some
uh
there was some discussion about Latin
America and Columbus Day and the offense
of Columbus Day and actually I do
believe that there is reason of all of
the things that we celebrate there is
reason
for us to rethink how we celebrate
Columbus Day but the Latin American
person who was responding to the idea
that Columbus Day was just simply an
affront was saying look
we understand we in Latin America
understand that this is the anniversary
of something terrible for us but it's
also our birthday
so you know here's the thing you've got
Portland you've got people who would
tear it down who wouldn't know the first
thing about what to do if it wasn't here
right they are simultaneously attacking
it and dependent on it and so the idea
to decolonize what does that even mean
right what careful what you wish for
right
um well yeah it is I mean we've
especially in the summer of 2020 we were
talking about this a lot but the people
who are the most outraged at the
terrible life that they are able to have
the United States uh I predict are the
least likely to have been anywhere else
right and they're also very likely
frankly to be from the privileged
classes these are these are you know the
protesters and the protesters were
actually a mix of of portlanders in the
summer and fall of 2020. the rioters who
reliably showed up or started doing
their rioting after dark for over 100
days straight
um we're much more represent a much
narrower demographic and it was much
more likely to be you know white kids
basically upper middle class well-off
white kids uh who were you know making
trouble yeah they were punks they were
yeah they were they were punks and my my
guess is
um that as interesting as this art is
you know this if this word was something
different uh you know we we'd actually
drove by this we were driving and just
paused stopped parked I didn't just
pause parked uh to uh to take a picture
of this and again this is last night uh
and it's really well done but the
message is incoherent the message is
incoherent decolonize
yeah okay so I also want to point out
um
uh something there's an uncomfortable
fact here the taxes that we pay here in
Portland are through the roof which I
don't think you know through the roof
isn't good it's not rational policy but
I don't think we either one of us would
be troubled by high taxes if we knew
that the taxes were high when we moved
here right and we have always always
been interested in paying our way uh and
you know paying our share
for services that are promised in return
for what we're paying right and the idea
that what we have is a city government
that has actually allowed the police to
be so antagonized that the police are
now reluctant to respond to 9-1-1 calls
it's like you're paying for your own
persecution right and that is a wholly
different matter so yes there's a way in
which it's odd to find us complaining
about taxes but the point is taxes are
for something right imagine going to a
restaurant where they just give you the
bill there's no meal you just get the
bill right do you keep going but maybe
they make you wash dishes and then they
give you the bill right
that doesn't make sense and it doesn't
make sense for a city either
all right you want to go ahead here
all right this is this marvelous truck
we ran into yesterday which sort of
explains the uh the confusion of of
Portland
um it's gonna be a little hard for us to
read it at this distance I don't know
that we should be showing this
I think you should take this off Zach
um I don't think we should be I mean
it's not okay that's that's fine yeah I
just there was most of a license plate
on that truck oh
right all right sorry my bad
um
so what we have here are I can't read
any of these but oh that there's two on
this side that that uh struck me as
interesting to have next to each other
on the bottom right read the bottom
right one Zachary
the woman with her back to us
okay the woman uh attractive young woman
with short hair with it back to us uh
with a speech bubble I think says have
you been catcalled what do you do kill
kill kill
and then on the same back of a truck on
the lower left
I think what it says and again we can't
we don't have a very good look at this
it's uh it says have you tried empathy
[Music]
well
um I'm not advocating for cat calls
I've certainly been cat called
uh and it's not cool but
those two encounter point with one
another are remarkable not remarkable
and it you know it is it it is
being able to have those two things in
your head enough you can put them next
to each other and not see the card and
not experience cognitive dissonance
um strikes me as some of the same mental
acrobatics that allow for the mass
formation we're experiencing
um society-wide right now right
actually the person who just cat called
you
you know maybe a psychopathic killer
might be a you know latent rapist almost
certainly not you know maybe just a you
know dude hanging out with other dudes
and it's really about the other dudes
and not about you at all that's ugly
that sucks maybe he's really interested
and he doesn't know anything about you
either you know except for the like
Psychopathic killer option this is a
this is a human being who is not showing
you respect at the moment but maybe
getting into their head a little bit as
opposed to saying have you tried empathy
lately and consider killing those who
cat call it's again incoherent on the
first Robin that you and I did together
um I said that cat calling is not a
compliment it's an insult right it's an
insult
killing is not the proper response to an
insult right this is a a Pistols that
Don might be yeah perhaps at least if
you both have the pistols but and then
you know there's another couple things
on here there's a something a weird uh
image of something Love Lock where
somebody's got somebody in a headlock
that's a an image that doesn't belong
anywhere and then in the upper right
hand corner here there's another little
sticker that's you know is a like a
cutesy little girl praying please kill
my enemies right and you know it is this
it's this incoherence this juxtaposition
of things that tell you that you're
actually not thinking clearly right yeah
um all right you want to move on
now this one I don't know what wow where
was this I didn't see this this is uh
over near City Liquidators for those so
this is east of the river uh for those
just listening not watching it's a tent
um that was someone living in it no this
is you can tell it's sitting on pallets
which are used to keep it from getting
cold and it's up against a wall it's
interesting like there's some nice mural
and there's some graffiti and it has
either painted or it's like a flat
there's a flag on the tent that says
Trump 20 20 20 20 did I say 2020.
he's gonna be long dead by then
um 2020 keep America great wow that's
isn't that amazing I'm not even sure
what to make I don't know if this is
well this guy might actually have a
point like he might be sick of of the
the mismanagement of of uh Portland and
the other West Coast cities or this may
be ironic I have no idea but in anything
but you saw this in 2022 yeah
yeah it's amazing
um so incidentally City liquid areas
which is a terrible name for a store uh
is an amazing basically two I think city
blocks of giant warehouses with
furniture and Taxidermy oh and some
weird antiques it's a strange strange
thing so Ultra antique like road signs
and such yeah it's amazing like I think
there's a Bob's Big Boy statue in there
there's all kinds of weird artifacts
it's a very highly recommended but again
actually that that is what Portland
should say right the interesting
furniture store with the crazy artifacts
yes totally
all right okay now I thought there's a
pair of little graffiti murals here that
I thought summed up Portland really
really where is this I don't recognize
this this is in the spring water
Corridor this is on the bike path on the
east side of the Willamette and I think
I actually saw the guy who was doing
this over the course of a couple days
in the middle okay so what we have here
is a hybrid between some kind of
psychedelic graffiti style and the
highly stylized Salish art that one sees
in the Pacific Northwest and in the next
image you'll see it even better but here
you have a kind of totem pole with an
owl-like creature on top and some
demonically grinning creature in the
Middle with some guy emerging from his
mouth and then a crazy frown with the
googly eyes in the bottom it's weird
it's a weird Distortion of that art and
you know
I don't I don't know how big is this
what are we looking at yeah it's about
the height of is about what a guy could
reach I think he did it so this is
pretty wide yeah it's not a pole it's a
Concrete pillar holding up the uh bridge
above oh so this is where you're going
under the bridge okay now go to the next
one this is a different pillar and here
you have same Artist as far as you yeah
I think it's the same artist so anyway
look at this like hybrid of uh Coastal
Salish art with yeah like psychedelic
like Ralph Stedman yeah exactly I also
think I see in here there was a cartoon
when we were kids in which there was a
demonic shark
I don't remember who the shark was it a
pink panther character on one of the
something there was a demonic shark and
I think this might be an homage to the
Demonic shark
um cartoon but anyway it's I look I
don't I am now so sick of graffiti that
I find it hard to accept even the stuff
that is obviously the result of extreme
Talent
um so this but this is on concrete that
was going to be bare concrete right I
still we can't live in a society where
you get to pick which bear concrete gets
to have what on it but nonetheless this
was obviously a talented person and what
they say is something I actually find
you talk to them I did talk to him okay
but what he's saying visually here is
I I'm not sure I like it but I find it
worth my attention there it is and that
I mean that's what art isn't supposed to
make you all fuzzy inside right
um inherently like some somewhere it
will but art art ought make you think
and this makes you think it makes it so
it keeps you looking draws your
attention uh probably I mean Drew your
attention long enough for you to
remember it when you were thinking about
what photographs to show today yep yeah
all right uh Advanced one
okay now here is a plant an abandoned
industrial plant on the shores of the
Willamette there are a number of these I
think this may have been a concrete uh
plant I'm not sure but it doesn't really
matter so off of the spring water
Corridor yeah off of spring water
Corridor right as you get towards the
Telecom Crossing
um and this one had a graffiti on it you
might be able to make it out if you're
if you're watching uh the video here but
it says something like
naive
antsy and BLM
and I thought that this was almost like
a free association that reveals the
mindset I mean I don't know maybe that
means something I don't know but at some
level okay naive antsy BLM like a man
you captured it inadvertently probably
but you captured it right yeah
um so anyway these things kind of speak
to what the weird Buzzy uh unhappy but
lashing out kind of strange ethos that
has increasingly taken over the city
okay yeah you're not you're not talking
about because it's weird and buzzy
can also have a positive valence and so
I said eclectic you know artistic
exploratory interest in Serendipity you
know there's the the Keep Portland Weird
crowd uh is interested in making you
know this is this is one of the one of
the places where maker culture you know
really took off and you know we have
craft we've grabbed everything all the
craft food possibilities you know the
beers and the and the ciders and the
ferments and the coffees and the you
know baked goods and the everything and
uh and all sorts of you you know more
Lasting products as well
but the you know what's getting
what's getting publicized uh what was so
public in the summer of 2020 is the
opposite of making it's breaking it's
it's unmaking yes and even if they're
creating an unmaker space even the tax
regime that we were talking about
has this as almost its uh its Central
effect so there are businesses here
really significant ones in some ways
obviously you know Intel and Nike but
there's also uh Golden West Billiards
there's Chris King headsets and hubs
there's high camp trailers yeah there's
a bunch of these businesses where people
are doing interesting high quality
things Innovative things but you know
frankly I don't know how you run a
business in this tax environment because
you're up against all of these people
who aren't paying such punitive taxes
elsewhere and so it just seems to me
like
it's really got to take something to to
stick it out here in Portland well and
especially I mean I I know I heard from
a number of people that especially
during the nightly riots when downtown
businesses you know first had had to be
shuttered for coveted reasons for
lockdown reasons and then they were
being destroyed there was just damage
happening every night not to individual
businesses for the most part but you
know I remember and we talked about this
at one point you know walking around
downtown in some beautiful morning and
seeing these shop owners out front
cleaning off the mess from the night
before like this should be their job it
shouldn't be their job at all so as you
know for any of these businesses that
are running running out of Oregon
um at all but especially Portland having
a high tax base without the benefits
from it or having a high tax rate
without the benefits from it is is a big
deal but especially for the small
business owners based in downtown yeah
where you know and and they started
going to Mayor wheeler at some point and
saying you know we we're going to leave
we have to leave how is it that you
expect us to run a business uh when you
know when all of this is happening and
at some level you know winter came that
first you know and you know probably
November December
of uh
2020 uh they're riots the riots picked
up again briefly after the election
like incoherently again well you
remember in the uh
they went after the Democratic
headquarters yep and they came out with
a sign this is what we were trying to
tell those who thought that this antifa
BLM group was actually on their side the
sign correctly said we are ungovernable
that's right that's right you know and
the point is look just listen to them
they're telling you yes they don't want
to be in a society and you don't you
don't clean up the messes of the people
who say we're ungovernable you don't you
know you don't offer them gift baskets
and to have them ask for space whips
which I wrote about initial selections
um when what they're clearly doing is
being facultatively homeless and taking
resources and you don't leave hold on
and you know certainly not everyone is
facultatively homeless but some some
number of people are saying This Is The
Life For Me and it's coming at the cost
of everyone else and most of the
homeless people you you you run into and
you see
um have had a series of bad luck and or
they are dealing with mental illness and
or they are dealing with addiction and
or they're dealing with city services
that are actually making it harder for
them to pull themselves out of the
problem rather than making it easier but
there was a story in Willamette Week
which is the free news rag that that
Portland
um publishes which I did donate to them
monthly for a while until they started
going after us at which point I thought
maybe I won't anymore
um
but they published this piece that I
wrote about Natural Selections about a
homeless person who appears to think
they're trans because he is wearing
pearls and makeup uh who is having his
homeless encampment moved across the
river and the local school said oh that
doesn't oh I don't know can we at least
get a perimeter where there's no like I
don't even remember what it was like
panhandling or something within 200 feet
I'm making up numbers here and some City
official responded by saying that's
racist
that these These are white people for
one thing like what are you talking
about and the school apparently respond
to that like oh God someone called us
racist that's terrible let's offer all
of the facultatively homeless people
gift baskets
and uh at least the person interviewed
in this story uh which I wrote about uh
asked uh to receive in a gift basket a
space whip which is a toy they use an
array of so you know this is not someone
who needs shampoo or a blanket or a tent
a place to lay his head down at night
this is someone who wants toys a 30-ish
year old person who um upon being you
know covered in the local newspaper
being homeless
um proudly says yep I asked for a space
whip
yep
um I've forgotten I had something I
wanted to add but I don't have it
um all right you want to advance one
uh so I did want to talk a little bit
about the what I think is the emerging
taxonomy of homelessness because I'm now
beginning to see that it's multiple
different things
um so what the image here is of is of
something that has become very very
common in Portland
um this is not the most common version
of it but this is a derelict vehicle I
guess it probably still runs
um many of them don't but this one many
of them don't this one looks like it
still might
Windows may be busted out I don't know
they're certainly down there are
blankets up over the windows this is
somebody's this is better than a tent
because it offers more security but
basically the idea is just as people
have adopted tents to protect themselves
in their homeless condition people have
now adopted vehicles and increasingly
over the last couple of years that has
been that has transitioned from derelict
cars to derelict RVs and so there are
places in the city many of them in which
you'll have a line of RVs and all of the
trash from the lives that these people
are living strewn out it just takes over
sidewalks it takes over uh empty lots
and it's it's uh disgusting it's
obviously a hazard a fire hazard
but in any case
so I see that there is a there's like a
permanently homeless population which as
we have discussed has a lot to do
um with addiction and mental illness
and then there are a couple of
populations which I wonder you know
homeless is kind of a euphemism in that
case because homelessness is not the
driving Factor even though people swear
that it is it's not enough homes the
rent is too high and the point is no
this is about a kind of dysfunction
schellenberger does a great job of
analyzing analyzing this and uh you know
the I can't remember what it's called
like the homes first or houses first
movement which is just taken over as the
only movement you're allowed to talk
about being part of if you're trying to
eradicate homelessness and you know he
argues in San Francisco
um that you know if we if we called the
population
uh something else and not like unhoused
not just moving the goal post because
it's fun to do so but identified that
actually there are other things that got
them here and there may be something
that they share but there's a there's a
there are exactly as you say different
populations and frankly
the you know the people who had bad luck
and a medical bill or uh you know the
death of a breadwinner sent them over
the edge into not being able to pay
their rent or their mortgage anymore and
now they find themselves on their street
with their family or whatever those
people definitely exist and it is the
responsibility of of a weird Society uh
to take care of them but they are I
think a very small fraction of the
homeless people that we are seeing well
I think they're a small fraction of the
homeless people that we are seeing
increasingly I am and partially this is
something that our move has revealed to
me is that they are moved to Portland no
our move from Portland the fact that we
are using storage facilities right to
juggle materials has revealed something
to me that I did not I had not
understood right which is what I think I
am seeing I don't know that this is what
I'm seeing but after many many
interactions
at these things often late at night you
know you're
you pack and you do whatever business
you need to do during business hours and
then late after things are closed you
take stuff to the storage locker to get
it organized one thing you're about to
allide though I haven't been is that the
storage locker is officially close at
10. so if you get in before you can get
in before 10 but then you can't get back
in so it's supposed to sort of shut down
after 10 and so you've been there
sometimes finishing up stuff as the
doors closed from the outside right and
what I think I see is people
using these storage lockers who appear
to be driving vehicles that are in
terrible condition and what I think I'm
understanding is people are using this
as a stop Gap I think they may be living
in storage facilities
um and you can imagine the trouble that
causes of some of these facilities don't
have a bathroom
um they none of the things that you
would rent have electricity but they are
climate controlled and so that a person
who can make themselves a lot cheaper
than rent right a person who can make
themselves unobtrusive can utilize this
it's surely safer than living on the
street and it's month to month so you
know you if you're like oh God you know
I I couldn't pay that last bill I lost
my apartment I need to hold on to my job
right I can get a storage unit for an
amount that's a third my rent and any
moment that I get back on my feet I can
move back into a real place yeah so
these people are
marginal but in terms of at the economic
fringes of society economically
marginalized they are not earning enough
to live in a way that most of us would
recognize but they are not on the
streets because they have cleverly
utilized this resource
um but in any case
nobody has said this to me it's just it
is what one puts together if you watch
the traffic at these facilities and you
begin to detect the patterns of who's
showing up when and all of that so
anyway I guess the point is look
you've got the tent homeless you've got
the derelict vehicle homeless you may
well have the storage facility barely
functional car homeless and there are of
course people in um in shelters and and
such I mean shelters have been defunded
in service of uh in service of creating
other kinds of housing opportunities
many of which again is schellenberger
outlines are a failure at the policy
level but certainly shelters do still
exist yeah they do and you know my sense
is that people use them sometimes like
bad weather will drive people to
shelters and things like that all right
can we uh move ahead here
oh now this actually we saw this last
night this is a Portland State Portland
State University this is the campus you
drive right through it it's in downtown
um and the inscriptions on the Windows
they have officially put signage in the
windows here that says
um
change isn't a maybe it's a must it's a
must
and
there's also a BLM sign in the floor
above in somebody's window somebody's
put it in their office window I guess
but anyway this struck me because
it reveals a kind of conclusion
I mean confusion and the confusion is
to say change is a must
there's a way I can defend that
statement I mean I've called myself a
reluctant radical because I don't think
we can afford not to change but you have
to say more than that change for its own
sake is insane right when you have
something that functions at all just
simply changing so that you're changing
is crazy and to have you know our local
University
broadcasting this message that we are
about to change without suggesting what
sort of change it might be that they're
interested in or suggesting that you uh
you support and it suggests you follow
that to its logical conclusion and there
is no state which will be satisfactory
right if change is a must no matter what
you know if there's no qualification of
of conditions then there is there is
nothing to which you can Aspire from
which you wouldn't want to change and
that is
again incoherent but also incredibly
Bleak it's incredibly
this is one of the blind spots of the
left and it's like a permanent blind
spot all right that once you realize
that you want change the you're not
doing the hard work of thinking about
what change you want or what would be
enough you know at what point will you
have achieved the thing that would then
cause you to stop demanding change
because you want the thing that you were
demanding it's like no no I'm a change
demanding person right
um so I always say that I'm a liberal
who wants to live in a world so
functional I get to be a conservative
and that's meant to cause you to think
but the the point is
look either you are asking for something
because you think it would be good at
which point you should try to conserve
it once it's there or you're not or this
is a fashion statement and there's way
too much of this liberalism as fashion
statement and you know it's driving the
city uh to uh tremendous dysfunction
indeed all right you want to move ahead
here
so here's just more homeless encampments
there everywhere this one's under the
entrance to the Tilikum crossing bridge
which I think is the next picture
yeah Telecom Crossing is lovely it's
it's I think the newest Bridge yeah in
Portland and it's only open uh to
Transit and to bicyclists and
pedestrians
and it's it's gorgeous it's sort of off
the
what the northern tip of Ross Island
just north of the Ross Island Bridge yep
uh and it's visible from most places
along the Waterfront along the
Willamette uh within the city and it's
really just very striking yeah and again
it strikes me as you know the tragedy of
Portland is all the greater because the
things that indicate the direction it
should go are here right this wonderful
bridge that encourages people to you
know to ride their bikes or walk or
whatever other mode of locomotion or use
public transit which can cross the
bridge right and it you know it looks
good it emphasizes the river is
everything good about this thing but at
the same time the decolonizers would
tear it down and then wonder why they
can't get across the river
you know
yep indeed all right move ahead
ah so this is
um that's a beautiful picture Brad yeah
uh I took that from my bike yeah riding
down
um this is the Riverview Cemetery which
is a gorgeous so you know all right
I would not have imagined myself really
loving a cemetery but I love this one
for several reasons one it's absolutely
beautiful
um in all seasons and the way the
seasons change and the cemetery is so
lovely and the cemetery which doesn't
have to has made
um
a way for bicyclists to use it to avoid
the dangerous roads that you would
otherwise have to use to get from the
Upland to the river yeah so this is in
the southwest uh quadrant of Portland
which is where we happen to have bought
we were we didn't know much about what
we were doing we bought and uh we bought
in just the right place just the right
place but in order to get down to the
river from here uh it took it took a
while
um but we and and then mostly you
figured out a number of back roads and
then you get to the entrance of the
cemetery and then they have as you said
opened up one route so you can't you're
not allowed to bike on all of the roads
in the center it's a vast Cemetery but
you can bike down to the river to get to
the Sellwood Bridge from from here it's
it is gorgeous and they've made those
allowances despite the fact that there's
obvious liability concerns but they've
done it and the bicyclists you know try
to respect the cemetery this is the
cemetery in which the bald eagles the
pair of bald eagles who lost their nest
were their tree fell down and they built
a new area and a second tree that I
covered on some podcasts it's in the
center of the cemetery anyway it's a
very beautiful place and the fact of
the juxtaposition of you know the Dead
with these very living fit cyclists
coming through again speaks to something
uh surprising and hopeful about the Way
Portland works yeah before we move on to
another photograph since I didn't since
because of the way things worked here
and the tech we don't have any pictures
from me in this in this slide deck but
sort of you you and I biked review
Riverview Cemetery a number of times but
uh you did a lot more than I did you
started doing this uh
uh well both going down to the nature
area down there which is Oaks bottom and
also you did the river to Summit the
nanson summit that we started one of the
pictures that you would go down and then
go all the way up and it was more than a
thousand feet because there were ups and
downs right more than a thousand feet
vertical climb
total and then back back down to our
house just about halfway between the two
elevations
um I often spent mornings at the
Japanese garden Portland's Japanese
garden which I don't have pictures of
here but it's it's fairly famous and
it's it's stunning and if you're a
member you can go early and and get in
before the crowds arrive and from there
if you can park up there and then walk
down through the Rose Garden Portland's
Rose Garden which is stunning and then
you walk down through Washington Park
and get into the Northwest District
Northwest 23rd and walk all the way to
the Pearl walk to downtown walk to the
Waterfront and all the way back and I
did that a few times specifically when
downtown and the Pearl and even
Northwest we're kind of we're looking
real dicey in the summer of 2020 and it
just felt like I don't know if I want to
leave my car unattended and still every
time we go down there we see a lot of
that you know the broken glass in the
street that shows that someone took a
hammer to someone's car window uh but
parking way up in the Japanese garden
and walking all the way down through to
first through a lot of beautiful
cultivated nature and then some
uncultivated nature and then into some
of the really really beautiful
commercial areas including by Powells
which is you know one of the best
bookstores on the planet
um is all all remarkable you can also
from there get easily to the Portland
Art Museum uh which clo you know
everything closed down during covid and
the patterns that I was beginning to
develop uh largely stopped so you know
Portland Art Museum being entirely
indoors did not open up as quickly again
as uh as did the Japanese garden and and
the Rose Garden but all of these oh and
for the first time I finally went to the
Pittock Mansion uh for the first time a
couple of weeks ago which is this
historic mansion that was built on say
around the turn of the last century uh
by someone who ended up helping to
create what would become Portland I
think if memory serves he ended up
starting out like clerking and ended up
owning one of the Portland newspapers
and so uh really contributed greatly to
to Portland and this is a historic
mansion with beautiful grounds around it
also associated with Washington Park
uh which you know the other thing that
we haven't said is that Portland has
three massive it has it has a lot of
small Parks but three massive Parks
Washington Park is several hundred acres
Tryon Creek which we're very near which
we can walk to uh is something close to
700 Acres I think and then Forest Park
is like 5 000 Acres which we've spent
almost no time in but
um these massive parks within the city
uh that allow people to get out into
nature without having to travel far to
do so all tragically overrun by Ivy
which again speaks to the promise and
the tragedy of the place because this
invasive species changes the nature of
these Parks dramatically it decreases it
and you know there is still a lot of
wildlife here in Portland but it is
distorted by the degree to which all of
these Parks have uh succumbed to this
this aggressive invasive species yeah at
some point we might I don't think today
is the day um but at some point we might
want to talk about what invasive species
are and why it makes sense to talk about
invasive species over in say plant land
or muscle land or whatever you know
non-human organism land but not about
um not about people not belonging in
particular places okay it's a different
ecological situation and English ivy
does not belong here and it out competes
so much else and yeah I can go with the
decolonized movement as far as English
ivy yeah and Scotch broom and
so much else yeah all right uh Move
Along here Zach let me
okay so this
is a gentleman I stopped to talk to him
uh he's a Latino guy who works I forgot
to check what the employer was but this
employer is he covering up the graffitia
making the graffiti and apparently it's
almost a daily thing
um this is recent yeah so this says for
people who aren't
uh watching there's like a teardrop with
x's for eyes and arms and legs that says
kill cops
and then it says antifa with both of the
A's as the anarchy symbol and TFA Hearts
you sure they do and then there's these
three arrows uh the antifa symbol that's
the antifa symbol yeah
um and anyway so this guy has been hired
I don't know what his job is supposed to
be but he comes out here and he cleans
up the graffiti again and again and
again and his employer he described
effectively as weekly
that is to say with great weakness
simply accepting that this is happening
and taking it upon itself yeah it's his
employers employers his employers
building and his employer is spending
money to have this guy repeatedly
cleaning up the graffiti that gets
written on there on a regular basis he
said it was something like nightly
and the tragedy where's that uh this is
again Spring Water Corridor
um the tragedy of the squandering of
this person's skill and labor on the
cleaning up after people who think kill
cops is a clever thing to write on a
building
right who and you know who haven't
understood that antifa is somehow a a
malignant Distortion of a very important
concept right fascism is something we
should oppose and be alert for and here
you have these people who have turned it
into a uh a flex right and they show
signs of fascism themselves
right why is this person's labor being
squandered cleaning up after these fools
that's it's just unconscionable but then
again here it is and I thought it
captured the tragedy of Portland pretty
pretty well
all right you want to move ahead
all right so this if you can scoot it to
the right a little bit
this is another
of the hopeful signs in Portland this is
one of our favorite restaurants this is
where we were last night G love G love
which before they opened uh the sign of
the door I don't know if they still
think of themselves that way but they
said I think it was called a reverse
Steakhouse
uh the logic being as they said on the
door
um that the vegetables come first and
the meat are the meats are available
um but that it's it's vegetable it's
vegetable forward with Meats for flavor
as opposed to a steakhouse where maybe
the vegetables are now right when you
get a side I don't know that they really
think of themselves that way anymore but
anyway I never even heard of the concept
before and I was actively looking
forward to them opening back in whatever
2019 when I was first walking the
neighborhood so the thing is it's a
really so if we haven't said it already
the food scene in Portland is
unbelievably good it's unbelievably good
the number of I mean you know you know
we grew up in La we've been to many of
the Great cities of the world we've
we've experienced good Cuisine but
nothing meets Portland for just for the
sheer number of different really high
quality restaurants and food trucks but
also the creativity of it right the this
place which has a menu that isn't like
any other place on Earth as far as I can
tell and you know this weird VW bus is
their signature van we saw people dining
in it yesterday I think you can special
request or reserve it somehow but it's a
really you know well restored VW van but
anyway it's a lovely Place full of it's
very importantly right if you look at
the clientele it's very importantly they
have a beautiful bar which I did not
quite capture a picture of the bar is
lovely their bathrooms are crazy they
have they're amazing bathrooms I'm not
gonna say what they are but they are two
radically different themes so if you
gotta pee you gotta figure out which
mood you're in yeah different
soundtracks even but it's it's like it's
yeah it's it's crazy you step out of
whatever meal mindset you were in and
suddenly you're in a very different
place anyway it's a cool place but and
the food the food is out of this world
it's dynamite it's so good but if you go
save room for dessert and get the
whipplicious which is a strange name but
it's a passion fruit thing that oh my
God it is extraordinary if if you can't
stomach saying it you can get somebody
else to order it for you but or just say
like I can I have that passion fruit
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah but anyway
it's a lovely place and you know if
Portland just leaned in and the staff
are awesome yeah yeah everything about
it's just everything about it is great
their cocktails are excellent
um by the way uh there's no better place
that I've ever been for people who can't
eat wheat
right Portland is excellent at taking
care of you nobody looks at you funny
they people know what doesn't have wheat
in general
um there are many restaurants that are
uh either wheat free or have a special
wheat-free menu anyway it's a place it's
a foodie place and it's a place that um
is not it's not arrogant about its food
it's really special and that's one of
the things that I will certainly miss
about yeah I mean we never watched
Portlandia I think we watched one
episode before we moved here and I'm
like whatever
um but there you know there people take
the food seriously here uh I don't think
anyone has ever asked to go visit the
chicken or whatever before it's killed
or whatever happens in that first
episode of Portlandia but uh it's true
you know if if you're not interested in
thinking about food at all then you
might view some of this as precious on
the other hand uh if you're really not
interested in thinking about food at all
if you've got any health problems at all
maybe you ought to start thinking about
food a little bit and the proximity in
Portland to one of the best growing
regions in the whole country you know
the Willamette River Valley is has
incredible agriculture as does East the
Cascades in Washington and we you know
we get incredible ingredients and people
really know what to do with them here
they're just the restaurants are
extraordinary
um and I don't know I've got a number of
other
we would miss some but maybe mention in
a couple other restaurants right now
unless you've got pictures of others uh
I wanted to say one General thing okay I
don't have pictures of others uh one
General thing which is that Portland
also did really well it's not the only
city that did this well but
um at the point that people finally
caught on that Outdoors was okay during
covid Portland did manage to move a lot
of its restaurants so the dining started
happening outside and they've kept it
yeah
um and so anyway there's a lot of dining
in the comparatively fresh air yeah
which is also super nice one of the
places that did that for instance was
Ankeny tap and table which has maybe the
best burger in town really incredible uh
another place that uh definitely
reconfigured uh was and I didn't look
into this so I'm going to get a little
bit of this wrong but tasty and Sun's
tasty and Alder tasty and daughters
tasty was a sort of a mini restaurant
Empire with extraordinary food I think
tasty another was my favorite restaurant
in Portland before covid I remember
going taking their taking John Wood
Junior there when he was staying with us
but they the whole the whole thing went
Belly Up in covet has so many small
businesses did but a couple of the
people who were involved in in tasty
then started another restaurant that
they're calling simply tasty
um close to us now
um South I think it may technically be
in Lake Oswego but it's other very
Southwest Portland OR Lake Oswego which
is amazing also and like G love and like
a number of restaurants in Portland and
maybe this is happening more widely but
they do the small plates thing where you
can order a lot of little things sort of
for the table and a lot of Family Style
Dining family style but family you know
family style sounds
I don't know 70s sounds different and
then like
you could certainly order stuff for
yourself if you want but uh I think it
frees up the kitchen tremendously not to
have to be like oh we got to get those
four plates out at the same time right
they can just it shows up you know and
the weight staff will tell you at all
these places oh lechon the Argentinian
place down near the Waterfront was
amazing
um kind of a steakhouse but uh they also
you know will you know you order stuff
and they'll come out whenever it comes
out but as long as you ordered food
that's amazing it doesn't matter what
shows up when so it actually speaks to
something I think maybe this is
happening elsewhere but to the extent
that a bunch of our favorite restaurants
and there are a couple we haven't
mentioned are doing the small plate
family style thing it actually Alters
the way
um it Alters the way dinner works right
and it's not even you know uh
family style in the way Asian
restaurants used to do it
um
it's it all kind of comes out at once
and you know there's a certain number of
dishes and yeah the this way
um
a it slows down the pace of the meal
right and B it uh it's definitely
different like you if you go to one of
these places alone or you and I go alone
it's like well okay it's many fewer
things and the idea of a lot of
different uh you know I guess Tapas was
always this way but
um
the idea of the variety that you get
um and you know sort of stop when you're
done uh is it Alters it Alters dinner
and it does fit with the Portland is an
unusual kind of place even at the level
of you know just dining at a good
restaurant indeed
um gosh there are a lot more uh I'm
forgetting many but I think uh
I think two that definitely weren't
particular mentioned because we spent a
fair amount of time there are rotigo on
Northwest 23rd which just does fabulous
grilled chicken and turns that chicken
into into chicken parts rotisserie
chicken and sandwiches and they have
actually mama bird does as well yeah
mama bird also
um and then lolis which is in Lake
Oswego uh for sure uh south south of
Portland but uh we've spent a lot of
time there and they do a um they do a
number of things brilliantly and the
staff there are also fabulous and uh
Steve turkey have already Apple
sandwiches particularly good yeah it is
uh all right you want to move on here
Zach all right this is um our cats who
did not know they were about to move as
they were about to move out of Portland
this is them enjoying uh what is our
very natural
um backyard Wilderness
um for essentially the last time they
are they are safely away from the
coyotes now yep all right
here is Maddie who uh if he's not an
insecure dog but somehow in US packing
she became concerned and so she climbed
into the driver's seat of the car to
make sure that we did not forget her
I think it's kind of an interesting
insecurity on her part so less less you
guys be concerned uh our younger son
Toby uh who I got started at the high
school up so we're moving we haven't
even said we've been to the San Juan
Islands and
um and Toby started up there now he's
got all the animals up there with him
and we'll be joining him shortly
all right
um
and here is Toby now I wanted to explain
this image this is an image people will
not be able to figure out probably I can
barely figure it out Toby
is wearing a full face helmet he is
sitting on one pedal of his electric
unicycle at night with the tail light
shining at the camera
and the headlight shining off forward
and this image came to be
because Toby called me he was out riding
his electric unicycle one night and he
called me up and he said
um hey Dad why don't you get your camera
and meet me at the spot
he said there's some owls and they're
doing crazy stuff and this was actually
just after my bike accident and although
it was only a couple blocks away it felt
like 10 miles away but anyway I hobbled
my way up there with the camera and
there were indeed these owls I think it
was a pair a mated pair and a baby owl
learning to do owl stuff and they were
right there and doing cool things but
anyway I thought
that this also spoke to
um the promise of Portland here Toby is
out at night no concern about his safety
here other than that he might fall off
that device
um and you know there's nothing normal
about electric unicycles or you know a
child exploring at night on his own but
um
this
you know that's also I've never seen
anybody sit on their electric unicycle
that way but in any case this struck me
as a pretty good image for keeping
Portland weird right it is actually in
both senses of the term right Portland's
an unusual place and it fits a guy like
Toby very very well
um and it's also as Heather was
mentioning earlier Keep Portland Weird
is
um
kind of the Dual theme we like both the
fact that Portland is an unusual town
right and we also like the fact that it
is a you know a testament to what
western civilization can be yeah um and
the fact that it would jeopardize that
over uh naive symbolism and gambling on
the possibility that if you wreck what
works that what will come back in its
place will be even better is just it's
mind-boggling the tragedy is really hard
to overstate
so maybe uh maybe that screenshot of the
of the new shirt now okay yeah you want
to show that uh well I'm gonna I'm gonna
miss
I'm gonna miss so much about this yep
Keep Portland Weird the new shirt says
and then in smaller font underneath
parentheses Western educated
industrialized rich and Democratic yes
that's our plea to Portland right you
don't want to give that up right a
prosperous City that uh is uh educated
and has the benefits of Western
Civilization
um does aspire to to democracy all of
these things are
um
uh things that you will miss when they
are gone and we are we are risking them
for for nothing
um all right you want to move ahead
uh so just a couple more images here
uh this is uh a not very beautiful image
but a interesting image of the belly of
a ferry boat
um oh uh headed to the San Juan Islands
um and then so we'll talk more about the
San Juans so some some of you will be
familiar with them and if you are uh you
will probably be thinking oh they're
lucky yeah which we are it's an
extraordinary archipelago we started
going
um when Zach was a baby so we've been
we've been going up there for 16 or 17
years and um often multiple times a year
and I've always wanted to go and because
it seems that Portland
needs to fix a lot of things in order to
remain weird in both senses of the word
uh we are we're going now yep and so
here's a ferry the ferry from Anacortes
in Washington uh over to the islands San
Juan Islands all right so now go to the
last image and I actually uh had a dual
purpose here so on the one hand uh Dark
Horse will absolutely continue as you
all know it will continue uh not in this
studio setting anymore so this is not
quite a sunset I should tell you
yes this is an unset this is this is an
unset and I want to explain what an
onset is an onset is when the sun has
set but you are either moving yourself
or you are on a moving object and it
causes the sun to re-emerge from perhaps
behind an island as it has done here
um and uh anyway so this is the unset
into which we are heading
um it's there's going to be a certain
amount of dust in reconstructing Dark
Horse we will continue to live stream
but the studio proper will not be you're
gonna build a new studio but there's no
even fiber to the to the place yet so
we're going to be including it for a
while uh our new place is fiber
deficient it is it's really backed up
yes the contractor who puts in the
fibers backed up but um that's not his
fault
um anyway all right in any case uh
that's about uh about where we've landed
oh man
I'm sad yeah me too yeah I'm sad and if
I was the kind of person who got angry I
mean it's not that I never get angry but
if I was the kind of person who got
angry easily I'd be really angry yeah
right this is needless Portland has what
it takes to be a great City and for it
to gamble what it's got on uh nonsense
fairy tales that anybody who knows how
to build anything knows aren't true
um is is obscene yeah
so we'll be coming back
um and I hold out
you know fantasies moving back at some
point but uh we will see let's see what
happens to uh to the world and to this
city in particular and uh
see if we can't
can't realize the goal of keeping
Portland weird
absolutely
all right is that it I think we're there
okay
um
so we will see you next week from a
makeshift space as we were in last week
on uh in the San Juans
uh no q a this week but we will be back
next week with a q a consider joining
our patreons reading our book our book's
been out almost a year uh to the day by
by next week it will have been out a
year and we'll maybe talk a little bit
about more about that uh remember to
Keep Portland Weird and you can find
that shirt at our store which is
somewhere
um that's going to be at
darkhorsestore.org that should be easy
enough to remember but apparently I
can't
um until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside resist calmly
[Music]